[Musique]
dans le cadre du concours du plus beau
collège fleur 2015 lancé par le Conseil
départemental les collèges volontaes
sont invités à repenser l'aménagement
d'un ou plusieurs espaces de leur choix
le collègean Albani à la possession a
pris le parti d'embellir sa cour un
projet porté par Laurent Albert
professeur d'espace rural et
environnement on a ciblé sur deux types
de de classe on a cblé sur donc les
classes de 4e et de 3e sea et notamment
deux ateliers donc priorité bien entendu
a été donné à l'atelier d'espace vert
qui qui est le mien et avec l'aide aussi
de l'atelier habitat qui est l'atelier
de des métiers du bâtiment notamment
pour la construction des
infrastructures un projet qui permet aux
élèves de découvrir les métiers liés à
l'urbanisme à l'architecture et à
l'environnement les collégiens sont
amenés à embellir leur cadre de vie ce
qui a un impact sur la baisse des
incivilités mais aussi sur
l'apprentissage c'est important parce
qu'il se raccroche à un projet il
s'appropri leur collège
et ça permet donc à tous les élèves de
tous les niveaux ainsi que
l'enseignement adapté la SEA dans le C
d'une politique d'inclusion de
travailler ensemble et donc de vivre
ensemble ai le jur s'est rendu au Jean
Alban plusieurs critères sont pris en
compte l'esthétique le travail les
efforts et l'ingéniosité du personnel
d'encadrement et des élèves difficile
est la tâche pour le jury mais le plus
important pour lui reste l'enseignement
des valeurs écocitoyennes et solidaires
fait aux enfants donc c'est c'est c'est
c'est un peu ce que je m'attendais voir
un espace qui qui ressort un peu du
collège et je pense que c'est le cas ici
au collège Jean Albanie on ne peut pas
ne pas voir le ré
donc je voulais vraiment féliciter
l'ensemble des élèves qui ont travaillé
là-dessus ce par quoi je suis le plus
touché c'est plus l'intégration et le
travail des élèves donc ça va être de
voir comment les élèves ont travaillé
comment ils ont été intégrés aussi dans
le reste de l'établissement comment le
projet va vivre après l'entretien et ben
oui surtout le le plaisir qui qui
peuvent peuvent montrer à avoir
travailler sur sur ce jardin alors
effectivement pour rentrer dans les
critères de détermination de du du
vainqueur entre guillemets il y avait
divers points très spécifiques le
verdissement l'amélioration au niveau du
paysage des
collégiens mais je suis un peu touchée
par autre chose aujourd'hui quand je
suis dans ce collège c'est ce qu' a
apporté ce projet au niveau au niveau de
la pédagogie de l'enfant quand un enfant
me dit voilà mes camarades sont venus
m'interroger dans la cour vont me
demander qu'est-ce que j'étais en train
de faire quelle est la plante que j'ai
que j'ai mis en terre ce matin je trouve
ça voilà juste formidable et et et je
pense que ça crée aussi des vocations
des élèves heureux d'avoir contribué à
l'embellissement de leur collège une
grande fierté de montrer leur travail et
leurs camarades et de laisser une belle
empreinte dans leur
établissement on a beaucoup participé
avec nos élèves à nous et grâce au prof
Monsieur Albert et Monsieur
Corbel on a fait beaucoup de choses et
le résultat je le trouve impeccable déjà
c'est un collège déjà beaucoup
fleu à plupart desjes collège il y a
beaucoup de mètres carrés de plantes
tout ça et je pense que là il m un peu
de guetté
voilà
[Musique]